اجيال مختلفه وفترات لمعاتهم
الفنيه مختلفه ايضا يعني مثلا راح انا
اقول فيما يخص السيده ام كلثوم الناس لا
تعرف من ام كلثوم الا فقط اغانيها المصوره
تلفزيونيه وهذه اخر عشر سنوات تعتبر ام
كلثوم دخلت في مرحله متقدمه جدا من عمرها
حتى من صوتها طبعا بينما اذا
نحن نقضيه والتاريخيه فيما يخص ام كلثوم
اهميه ام كلثوم في الثلاثينات والاربعينات
والحان من ملحنين ليسوا اللي استمروا معها
في اخر عشر سنوات يعني من بين بعد 63
ميلادي حتى
الناس تاخذ كل التفاصيل هذه عن تاريخ فنان
تكلم عن الجمله الموسيقيه الكلمه الحلوه
اللي كانت موجوده في ذاك الزمن الجمله
الموسيقيه زي ما ذكرت الروايه العظيمه
اللي كانت موجوده الفيلم اللي كان موجود
فيه المسلسل وغيرها من الامور يعني في زمن
مختلف يمكن حتى مرتبط حتى مش قيمه فن لازم
يكون في التئام بين الاثنين الزمن والفن
يعني انه ضمن بيئه اجتماعيه واقتصاديه
وثقافيه من حق الناس في كتابات مثلا في
فتره ام كلثوم وعبد الوهاب تشن عليهم
وتمدح الزمن الجميل تقصد الزمن اللي هو في
القرن التاسع عشر برضو حلو يعني بالتالي
هنا رجعنا لسالفه اختياريه انتقائيه وهذا
خطر طبعا ذاكره لكن هي تشكل الذوق الشخصي
هذا امر لا علاقه له بالدراسه التاريخيه
او النقديه يعني لا لا علاقه هذه هي
الحقبه الذهبيه للفن والادب في العالم
العربي لا مرينا بحقب كثير في اكثر من
يعني 1500 عام في كذا حقبه عندنا اذا
بنتكلم على مثلا انه واحد الثقافي يعني
الزمن الجميل الجيل اللي راح يعني هنا بس
خلينا ما نطلع انت ما تعتقد انه هذه تعتبر
حقبه
ذهبيه اكثر من الوقت الحالي اللي شفنا
نشوف فيه اغاني اي كلام
يعني من الصعب الكلام لاني لا يمكن اسمح
لنفسي اهضم حق للموجودين الان واللي الان
عندهم فاعليه عاليه جدا في انتاجهم الفني
والادبي لانه بعد عشره سنوات ممكن نقول
كلام ثاني لو التقينا يعني فبنقول ممكن
كلام ثاني يمكن يطلع للان احنا يمكن
نغمض حقه في مقابل نعله من الشائن السابق
انه نفس القصه يعني نكرر نفس المساله يعني
لكن في كل فتره هناك جميل في كل فتره في
زمن جميل يعني
معيار الادب والفن كان اكثر رصانه كان
بعيد مثلا عن السمات التجاريه والسريعه
اكثر من ما هو موجود حاليا اللي تغير فيه
الزمن دخلت فيه الماده بشكل كبير شوهت
كثير من
اللائقه حتى الفنيه للناس الفنون والاداب
تقوم على مؤسستين دائما هي وحده مؤسسه
معنويه وفي مؤسسه ماديه
ولا تقوم للفنون ابدا ولا الاداب قائمه
الا بهالمؤسزتين الجانب التجاري له علاقه
بمساله اسمها الاستهلاك اللي هو فائض
انتاج هذه مساله يمكن
لا يعني يعبا فيها الا الاشخاص اللي مثلا
يحسبون بالارقام طبعا الربح والخساره يعني
او التلف في لكن احنا معيارنا لا يهتم
بالامور هذه يعني عشان كذا راح ارجع
للقضيه الانتقائيه انه احنا ننتقل يعني
انت ممكن تجد انه ام كلثوم هي المهمه لكن
تاريخيا هناك فتحيه احمد لوردكاش هناك
ماري جبران هناك نادره امين في اكثر من
شخصيه
نفس القفه في ما يخص عبد الحليم ايضا هناك
محرم فؤاد ومحمد رشدي وفي شفيق جلال وفيها
كارم محمود في مجموعه نفس الشيء فيما يخص
محمد عبد الوهاب ايضا كان في فتره يعني
يجاهد ايضا اسماء اخرى يعني فبالتالي من
الصعب انا انه اختصر جيل في شخص لكن انا
ما اقدر امنع انه حب الناس يخص عبد الحليم
حافظ ما يقدر نمنعه